welcome back everybody we've got Sophia
V with
us the new Netflix series is called
gelda it's about a Colombian woman's
unlikely rise to become one of the most
notorious crime bosses in Miami and if
you're a Crime Boss you've always got to
be looking behind you so it's time for
another round of what's creeping up on
[Applause]
me's all right so here's how it works
Sophia will start with her back to the
screen I will give her clues about
what's creeping up behind her which I
normally am not super great at so
whatever I can't say the name of the
thing I just got to describe it so then
we're going to switch sides and Sophia
will give me clues hopefully she's
better um we can pass if anything is too
hard to guess which I always forget by
the way and should totally use that um
if we can correctly guess 10 things
total in two rounds Sophia has a prize
for the audience so let's get into
position I'm not going to wait what
things things in general or movies or
anything in the world I have no idea
what's about to happen I am so bad at
this game oh great that's why they like
me to
play like yeah well it's the Kelly
Clarkson show so who knows here we go
all right so um I'm ready go now okay oh
you're on the ocean on a m a craft of
some sort and you're going it's not a
jet
yes go quickly oh what oh when people
die they're in the morg and they put
their names on like something on their
feet to and put like you know Jane do on
their feet you know like a like a okay
when you're a kid you played a game and
you would go and chase them and you
would you will scare them next
next next okay oh this is oh the
friendliest little thing in the ocean
and they they go in like um they swim
like this and they dive up and down the
seal no no but um flipper Skipper what
does na name oh the Dophin yes
yes okay so you the character you play
went
to jez which is also
called
punishment which is also called what's
another word for jail prison okay
cool oh this is like this is like people
do it on the boardwalk and at bad
dancing uh no like what what is
that
I don't dance like that you know es
skateboarding no roller blading roller
skates you got it
okay oh this happens in in Florida a lot
um and it's like the wind is crazy the
ocean's crazy
okay oh this is like prehistoric and in
the dinosaur well it kind of it's
prehistoric in a sense of like but it's
still around um and it's and it's not a
crocodile it's not a crocodile it's a
it's an it's a c the other one not a
crocodile dinosaur no it's not a
crocodile it's the other one the shorter
hippopotamus um you can get boots that
are made of this of
crocodiles what of a
snakes you're so
horrible I love that you said I dance
like switch switch you can see how it is
I do not dance like that concate
concentrate okay okay I'm in I'm in okay
go
okay and you go around oh hul yes yeah
yeah Gela made money money that cash do
yes and in Miami there's a lot of Pink
Flamingos they really good and then in
the pool when you go ah you dive are you
are okay yeah but it with your
Cannonball or belly flop yes
[Applause]
okay they're in the in the land in the
and you go and you it's an insect you
didn't even say insect till just now I
don't do you know how many things could
bite you or sting you or a b no in floor
it's it's from the floor I mean
really F
really you think I Weir if you didn't
get
alligator you're a an
alligator I want to do a game night oh
we got it oh we got oh that was a bonus
we got we did it we did it 360° sunare
products are driven by science and
Innovation to help preserve your skin
health and make you feel M Bonita they
are vegan crueltyfree and full of is it
Allegria alria alria uh just like their
founder Sophia is that Joy is that where
yes happiness I like it okay and you're
all going home with a $200 toy gift
card give it up for sopia V you failed
that game so fast we faed it we did good
be sure to watch our new series geld
premier's tomorrow on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home